[Music]
chuck we're back
yes
yeah what do we got topic for you
all right
uh
what the
zoom calls
and einstein's theory of relativity
haven't gone
um no one knows how either of them
actually work
that's a good answer i'm gonna say
that's gotta be the answer
that's a good that's a good answer so
here you go you ready
okay let's do it uh what we learned what
we affirmed in einstein's theories of
relativity is that space cannot be
thought of
just as space
time is a fundamental coordinate right
alongside space
so when you ever want to think about
events phenomena past present future you
have to think of space time you can't
just think of space or time as separate
things and there's an entire set of
equations that fold the two together
that's see now that's
the first part
i am so cool with i like literally get
it
you know
but when you talk about proving it
mathematically
i'm still
just that's how you know it's gonna be
tight that's all yeah of course because
it keeps keeps moving it keeps working
when it when the map works it works yeah
it works right okay so
um
lettuce for those who might still be
uncomfortable with the space-time
concept
what you don't know perhaps is that you
live that way
there's no other way you you live it's
so intuitive you think it's complicated
but it's easy
so if i say to you chuck
you ready okay i'll say
uh chuck
uh let's have lunch tomorrow at noon
i would say
oh my god as long as you're paying
that is such a wonderful offer okay
chuck it's on me let's have lunch
tomorrow at noon what is your next
comment back to me where where do you
want to eat where do you because the
time
alone was insufficient
for
for your life and my life to intersect
time is
alone will not make that happen you also
have to give
a spatial coordinate
is it the diner on the corner of you
know
hollywood and vine
at 12 noon so you have a space
coordinate and time coordinates so that
we can both meet
right okay
by the way leave it to you to give me a
coordinate where you know i can't get to
so watch if you go to the diner at a
corner of hollywood and vine right
yesterday and i go there tomorrow
we were in the same place
we were
but not at the same time
okay it doesn't work okay
we're both in the same place
but not at the same time
right okay
which which is what i call neil's
favorite lunch
chuck yeah you were here yesterday good
okay so now watch so now you're at the
diner in the corner and i'm at with this
works with starbucks you're in that
starbucks i'm in a different starbucks
okay
we're at the same time
but not at the same place
right yes it's the same brand but it's a
different location yeah but it's a
different location yeah okay so you need
to be at the same place and at the same
time for anything to happen where you
have two things that want to coordinate
together right okay all right
so how does this manifest let's go in
the universe and there's an asteroid
headed towards earth
you could do the bruce willis thing and
what
blow it up blow it out of the sky which
it takes a lot of waste and energy or
you can deflect it
well how do you deflect a good destroyed
not a good movie
how do you deflect an asteroid so here
it is if you left it alone
it will collide with earth
which means it will be in the same place
at the same time that earth is sometime
in the future at some point in the
future okay
so what i can do is i can speed up the
asteroid
oh
i love that
oh
you speed it up
then it gets to that location in my
orbit before i do exactly
so it's at this we're exist at the same
time but we're not in the same place
that's a whole
that's a whole nother way to look at
deflecting an asteroid that's what's
going on when you deflect an asteroid
that's awesome
or you could slow it down then we get to
that point before it does we keep moving
and it goes right on by behind us oh man
it's the proverbial um
mental
uh exercise that everyone
does when they have a car accident
if only i hadn't forgotten my keys
if only i had left a little bit earlier
i would have never in that spot at that
time for exactly for the drunk driver
correct exactly right yeah it's a mental
calculation you do
right right and and it works in simple
ways that we don't even talk about but
it's so simple you cross the street five
minutes later a bus drives down the
street
you didn't say oh my gosh i was old i
was almost hit
oh you're a bit of a drama queen you
know that right
it was almost hit by a bus did you see
that
what no it came by here five minutes ago
it's barely just barreling down this it
was in the same spot i was right there
i could have died
right you would not have died and by the
way in relativity we call these world
lines your world line is
where you are in space and time which is
always in motion
right because time as a even if you're
sitting there on your butt right you're
moving forward in time right
by the way this affects time machines
all right if i give you a time machine
and you say okay you want to go
um uh into the future how far do you
want to go in the future oh i'm going to
go at least 200 years just to see if
we're still here okay but suppose you
say all right i don't want to land in
the winter let me land in the summer so
i want to go 200 years in six months
okay okay let's say because we're
recording this it's cold outside right
now right so you do that all right so
you go we'll go in your time machine go
200 years and then you walk out of the
time machine you will suffocate in the
vacuum of space
because
earth is it's not just spinning it's
moving while it's spinning okay so you
will land in the same spot that earth
was in its orbit
which is a different place than where it
is six months from now
oh man which tells you a time machine
can only work if it's a space-time
machine that's right
that's pretty awesome you want to move
to a location in time and a location
in space
correct right
all right so
oh wow that is really cool because okay
so now watch
watch how this plays out are we are we
on the same page now i want to move
forward until i hear neil i'm with you i
am riding this wave with you buddy okay
okay
so
um under normal circumstances i'm in my
office three or four days a week i
travel a lot
um there are seminars in colloquia
scientists come through the department
and they give talks
you know if i'm around i'm gonna attend
those talks because they're good they
learn about the latest breaking
discoveries made by my colleagues okay
so we get we have maybe three or four
talks a week in our division at the
american museum of natural history and
used to make maybe one of those a week
all right
however
during covid
i was making four out of four talks a
week
okay why
because zoom calls
broke the space-time alliance
so that now you only have to be at the
same time and you do not have to be at
the same place
interesting as a result world lines can
split and only conjoin on the time
coordinate
rendering the space coordinate
irrelevant
um but that is why probably more people
are attending more conferences seeing
more meetings
than ever before
you can no longer use an excuse oh i'm
on a on a business trip i can't come in
zoom in
we have you on the gym call
i know
it's an electronic leash is what it is
for most people and that's how chuck you
spent how many months you were filming
brain games for national geographic
you're their new host in their new
season yet you didn't lose a bit of this
schedule your background was different
because you were recording with us via
zoom through your hotel rooms and other
setups that's right and so
so we you were still participating
because your world line didn't need the
space coordinate
that's true and so this
is the relationship between zoom calls
and einstein's theory of relativity
that is uh that's pretty wild
and um
in a way i have a new respect for zoom
now
uh
for breaking the space time continuum
yes exactly it's like who knew zoom was
so damn sci-fi
[Laughter]
oh that's pretty that's it yeah
i love it now in all fairness to prior
means of communicating that predates
zoom the telephone was kind of like that
yeah all right and by the way
do you know what the word caller meant
before there was a telephone
uh it was a visitor to you front to your
front i was gonna say um
a handsome gentleman perhaps yeah you
have a gentleman caller
oh i do believe you have a gentleman
calling yes exactly that's the meaning
of that with the original meaning of
that word and then
alexander bell invents a telephone and
so what word are you going to use when
you show up at the front door of the
telephone line
it's a caller it's a caller and now
that's we've been that way for a hundred
and you know 30 years or whatever so we
150 years now so 1876 was the
demonstration of the patent for the
first telephone um and
so
that
put people together in time without
having to be together in space wow
that so so this is what this is like one
of the great achievements and advances
in modern civilization
uh and zoom just did it full up with
voice and sound and audio quality and
saved files and everything it's it's
really funny because the video call was
purported to be the thing that would
change everything in society
i remember seeing a video phone in 1964
world's fair in new york
wow that's the future then you realize
you call someone at six in the morning
they don't want you looking at them
yeah exactly
people don't always want you looking at
them anytime you happen to call them
what is that on your face don't look at
my face
let's just have a call stop looking at
my face
so now you can pre-schedule zoom calls
and now you can get all dolled up and
look all party
zoom purty yeah you got to that's pretty
uh that's great though i mean it's it's
who knew that you could link this back
to einstein i said you had a tough one
but you did it you linked it back to
einstein somehow
and now you know with asteroids we're
just changing his world line yeah which
by the way that is the coolest thing
ever the fact that i mean you and the
idea is you don't even have to knock it
off course you just speed it up or slow
it down that's because you always think
of deflection as a change in
the sideways and the right character
right right well a vector is direction
and space and speed technically a vector
has both of those components so if you
change its direction or you change
changes you've changed its velocity the
velocity is the combination of those two
so it's exactly right it's but that's
great it's like that i mean i am less
scared of asteroids now
still be scared i don't want that was
not the point of this explaining okay
by the way a velocity
vector
is motion that has direction and
and and speed as part of it like the
asteroid right right so you can change
its direction or change its speed
or both
either of those are changing the
velocity of the asteroid okay so now
watch you can do that
so with a car there are three ways to
change its velocity
right you can slow it down you can speed
it up and you can hit a wall or another
ideally not okay you can slow down that
reduces its speed you can
accelerate increase its speed or
you can change direction
okay
all three of those
can help you avoid an accident right
it's not just how good your brakes are
do you have a place to steer
so that your world line does not fully
intersect with the one that would cause
the accident uh you know what as a
person who rides a motorcycle you just
explained
how you stay alive on a bike those are
the three things that are your friend
that they teach you all the time the
first is acceleration get up and get out
of the way the second is being able to
brake properly but now motorcycles have
anti-like breaks so that used to be a
big deal not so much but the most
important is being able to maneuver so
you know to to to be able to motorcycles
are particularly nimble in that regard
exactly right yeah right super cool
there you go okay chuck got a call
adequates all right all right all right
that that's not yet another start talk
explainer neil degrasse tyson here keep
looking up
[Music]
you